цінуємо присутність мудрості та
всіх учасників, що свідчить про
важливість, яку ви надаєте
запуску візової програми, і ми робимо компакт-диск, який
буде щасливий, що буде використаний, щоб стати свідком
цього моменту, щоб ви реалізували свою
мрію стати частиною міжнародного
спільнота оцінювання навчання та PLO
me Я також хотів би подякувати польським експертам,
які з нами, це також привілей
для нас мати таку
взаємодію між країнами, це
насправді принцип Пізи, який полягає в тому,
щоб ініціювати навчання між  країни
також міжнародні експерти та національні
експерти приєднуються до цього заходу, тому я сподіваюся, що
ви зможете провести змістовні дискусії
навколо vita та інших освітніх
доказів, які будуть використані в дискусіях щодо політики,
тому ми хотіли б піти
на прес-конференцію о 10. Я
хотів би зробити  перша частина моєї презентації
тривалістю 10 хвилин, потім я
продовжу докладну презентацію пізніше,
щоб моя презентація зосередилася на тому, що ми
можемо дізнатися з  m Visa, щоб у вас було
більше ідей щодо того, які
докази ми можемо отримати від Visa,
які питання політики, на які ми можемо дати
відповідь за участі pisa
pisa, стосуються міжнародного порівняння
результатів освіти та
контексту навчання до
студентів, чому це важливо, тому що піца
допомагає країнам зрозуміти, де ви
перебуваєте або як інші країни
працюють, і що роблять інші сильні
виконавці, щоб ви могли
знайти, де ви перебуваєте, а також чого ви
можете навчитися у країн, які стикаються з
подібними проблемами, які можна було б зробити
плавання через океан
освітніх результатів за допомогою
уроків PISA про піцу, я будую на основі
останніх даних цих RPG 2012 для піци,
понад півмільйона студентів у
всьому світі взяли участь у тесті, і
це тест на основі вибірки, тому
це фактично 28 мільйонів  студенти
у різних країнах, понад 60
країнах у 2012 році у віці 15 років і
студенти сидять за двома іншими, щоб взяти t  o
пройдіть цей тест, який дещо відрізняється
від традиційного тесту, це не
тест на розуміння знань, які
мають учні, а ми просимо
учнів розв’язувати задачі, використовуючи знання,
які вони засвоїли в школі, тому
це насправді про компетенції
та як  учні можуть застосувати те, чого вони
навчилися в школі, у ситуації, з
якою вони ніколи не стикалися,
що насправді відбувається в повсякденному
житті молодих людей і дорослих, які
їм доводиться постійно протистояти новим
проблемам, і вони повинні думати про
нові способи.  розуміння та
вирішення проблем, тому такіза – це випробування
життя. Піза охоплює читання з математики та
наукову грамотність кожні три роки, потім
ми додаємо інноваційні галузі 2012 р. ми
запроваджуємо вирішення проблем, і іноді
країни вибирають факультативні дослідження, наприклад,
фінансові галузі, тоді студенти також
відповідають на анкети  це допомагає
країнам краще зрозуміти
контекст навчання та викладання студентів
у класах  o щоб ми могли зрозуміти
та співвіднести історію учнів
з їхніми результатами, а також краще
зрозуміти їхню участь у навчанні
свого навчального середовища та яку
підтримку учні отримують від вчителів
зі шкіл від батьків і країн,
які також використовували анкети, щоб задавати
запитання батькам або  У 2018 році є
можливість задавати запитання
вчителям та керівникам шкіл, щоб ми
також могли краще зрозуміти, як
результати учнів пов’язані з практикою шкільної політики
та що відбувається в
класах, це консолідація
міжнародного досвіду. Я не може
бути виконаний лише однією країною
це група з ви знаєте 18
країн, які приєднуються до військово-повітряних сил, щоб
разом розробити оцінку піци, тому
Україна зараз бере участь у цьому дослідженні Ісуса,
це користь для України, але
це також користь для
міжнародної спільноти, ви як дуже
важливий  ви додаєте дуже важливий
актив до бази знань
міжнародного задника  Тому ми з
нетерпінням чекаємо та вітаємо
внесок України в мир і
розвиток, а також розвиток Пізи
керується питаннями політики, які ви
задаєте, нам потрібні політики всередині, щоб
поставити правильні запитання в потрібний момент,
тому ми повинні отримати  розуміти,
які питання ви обговорюєте,
яка інформація вам потрібна для формування вашої
політики, тому ми постійно ведемо
діалог з політиками
країн-учасниць, щоб
оцінка піци була актуальною для
формування політики. Ще одна сильна сторона Пізи
– це порівнянність, яку ми гарантуємо  і ми
мобілізуємо найвищий технічний досвід
для порівняння в різних
країнах, різні мови та
різні культури, і ми
тріангулюємо дані учнів з іншими джерелами даних,
включаючи школи, і припускаємо, що
вчителі та батьки, і ми використовуємо дуже
передові методи для розробки
конструкцій, розроблених для оцінки та
аналізу
просто дати вам деякі ідеї типу
із питань, які ми задаємо студентам
на піцу, це дуже простий
приклад тестового запитання, у якому студентам задається, що ви
знаєте, що вони 200 000 людей піднімаються на
гору Фудзі з 1 липня по
27 серпня, тож скільки альпіністів прокладають
це простий підрахунок
середнє значення цього тесту, тож,
чекаючи зображення, я просто даю вашим легеням,
що цей тест призначений для перевірки базового
рівня знань, тому це один із
найпростіших пунктів у Пізі, велике дякую,
щоб оцінити здатність
учнів визначити  середні щоденні ставки, тому
це потрібно для розуміння кількості
розуміння учнів у даному
контексті, пов’язаного з повсякденним соціальним
життям учнів, а не так, як підйом на
гори за межами школи та
формулювати рішення, це більш
складні математичні задачі для вимірювання
максимальної дуги  тривалість цього переміщення
витримати це текст для читання Джен
студенти відповідають, яка тема
цього тексту, це також один із
найпростіших пунктів  Піза має рівень знань,
шостий – найвищий, один –
найнижчий, а другий – базовий
рівень, який усі молоді люди,
незалежно від потреб своєї країни, мають
отримати, щоб підготуватися до свого майбутнього,
а майбутня піца блогу також має
відкриті продукти, це не лише декілька
вибір ми просимо студентів прочитати текст
і зрозуміти розмову між
студентами, і вони відкрито формулюють своє
розуміння та відповіді, наприклад,
для цього пункту, наприклад, ми бачимо, що в
країні лише приблизно половина студентів отримує
правильні відповіді, і у нас є дуже хороший
код у керівництві  Я лише наводжу деякі
з перших результатів,
які ми можемо отримати з Пізи, це,
ймовірно, те, з чим ви
знайомі, це список
країн за допомогою математики, і
ви можете побачити рейтинг країн
за  результат, який є одним із вимірів для
розуміння якості систем освіти,
наскільки 15-річні
підлітки обманюють масу, але ще один дуже
важливий ди  Згадка про те, що я дає,
це еквізити, просто фальшивий високий
бал недостатньо навіть для того, щоб поставити
запитання двом країнам, наскільки
студенти, незалежно від їхнього соціально-
економічного дна, мають шанс
досягти найвищого потенціалу, ми бачимо середній,
але також відносно незначний вплив
соціально-економічного  статус щодо успішності студентів,
тож там, де ви там,
вони від студентів, вони мають, як ви знаєте,
хороші шанси на хороші результати, тоді як
країни в червоному камені, їх
результати нижче це середнє, але
також вплив соціально-економічного
походження студентів  багато, тому
це дає певне уявлення про
рівність освіти
в країнах, люди можуть сказати, що
деякі країни, як-от Корея та Японія
, працюють добре, тому що вони
витрачають багато грошей або вони багаті,
але насправді якщо ви бачите рівень
витрат  картина не така
проста, якщо ви бачите країни,
а бульбашка — це розмір грошей,
який вони є  очікуючи на студентів,
схоже, що деякі країни
працюють добре, як кам'яний двір Японія
Корея, вони витрачають на студентів автобусів,
насправді менше, ніж деякі інші
країни в деяких країнах, як-от ніяк не
коричнева справа або
Люксембург великий червоний міхур  вони
витрачають багато на більшу суму, але
їхня продуктивність не така висока, як в
інших країнах, це означає, що
іноді гроші самі по собі не пояснюють,
що йдеться про те, де зосередитися методист і
як ефективно використовувати ресурси,
мабуть, я витратить ще дві хвилини,
щоб  підкреслити, хто працює краще або
покращує Німеччину в Туреччині Мексика
продемонструвала значне покращення
ефективності, але також вдало, тому
країнам було б цікаво зрозуміти,
що відбувається в цій країні та
що вони зробили для покращення своєї
діяльності, деякі інші країни
також зробили значний  збільшення
маси між 2003 і 2012 роками, а також
важливо скоротити розрив, тому що в
усіх  країни існує значний розрив
між студентами з найвищим соціально-економічним рівнем та нижчим соціально-економічним рівнем,
і питання політики
полягає в тому, як скоротити розрив, як
дати можливість усім студентам
добре працювати. Німеччина розрив
говорив про 2000 рік,
найкращі соціально-економічні
студенти сягнули 570, тоді як
ті, хто з нижньої чверті, лише
450, вони доклали зусиль, щоб скоротити розрив,
і особливо вони підвищили
успішність студентів із
низьким соціально-економічним рівнем тоді, як
результат  вони покращили середній показник США
у них також є великий розрив, і вони
скорочують розрив, але як вони це зробили, вони
підвищили результативність нижньої частини
соціально-економічних кварталів, але найкращі
виконавці зменшилися, вони не покращилися,
тому в результаті кішка скоротилася, але
загальна продуктивність насправді не була  зміна
Польщі не дуже цікавий випадок, вони
добре зробили як для підвищення
успішності студентів із нижчими соціально-економічними
мовами, так і для
підвищення успішності, а також інші результати,
загальні досягнення показали
значне покращення, тому це свого
роду аналіз, який ми повинні  робити
порівняння між країнами, але також
важливо потреби країни в
більш глибокому аналізі даних країни,
щоб ви ставили відповідні питання для
ваших політичних дискусій для вашого
політичного стилю, щоб, як сказав міністр,
ви могли отримати об’єктивні докази, які
вписуються в  політичні дискусії